this is not meant to be Sensational
right there's no need for us to
sensationalize any data but the truth of
the matter is for the last two to three
years now guns have been the leading
cause of death among kids
Physicians are treaters of the sick and
preservers of the healthy so there
really is nothing else that a group of
Physicians would rally behind other than
saving lives this epidemic is uniquely
American
gun violence is a public health issue
and a health care issue this is not
Democratic or republican this is just
protecting humans sometimes you have to
lose sometimes you have to push a
boulder up a hill and it has to crash
back down on you but you won't succeed
without ever trying
America supports all these bills and it
needs to be the time now where the
politicians realize that if Government
doesn't back us that they're going to be
voted out exactly we have seen that when
we take Public Health approaches that we
save lives
[Music]
motor vehicle accidents are no longer
the number one cause of death of
children because of safer cars and car
seats we can use that same public health
approach to discuss guns and gun safety
legislation and create meaningful change
how can we as medical experts help you
guys so what do you need do you need
more doctors from your state that we can
help provide you to provide evidence do
you need us to come to hearings for you
we are here to collaborate with your
office to whip these votes because we're
sick of letting children die every day
a typical day is going from meeting to
meeting no breaks lobbying all day and
presenting our statistics and data and
research I usually try to open and say
my name is Dr Emily Lieberman I'm a
pediatrician a wife a mother I am now
also a mass shooting Survivor
and I have the unfortunate but unique
perspective of now being a survivor of
gun violence and also a pediatrician who
treats people in the community who have
suffered from gun violence
and I think that sets us apart from a
lot of the other meetings
we live in Highland Park which prior to
July 4th of last year I think anyone
would say was probably one of the safest
appearing communities in the country
we're kind of Pleasantville for lack of
a better word on our nation's most
patriotic Day July 4th our family woke
up put on Fourth of July attire and met
with cousins and my parents our children
were in the streets there was laughter
we're waving to politicians and then all
of a sudden there is a horrible popping
sound overhead
and it becomes clear very quickly that
this is a gun
seven people were killed and more than
48 others were injured after a gunman
opened fire at a Fourth of July parade
in Highland Park Illinois
according to the gun violence archive it
was one of 647 mass shootings that took
place in 2022. unfortunately we've
learned that we can't keep our children
safe when most of these weapons are on
the streets but what we can do is help
prevent these shootings from continuing
to occur which is what we are here to do
now for the rest of our life
foreign
[Music]
and so typically when a patient rolls in
they're going to be lying down here and
this is where the anesthesiologist is
and then once the patient is asleep the
whole team kind of functions you know
very much as a well-oiled machine we've
here on the front lines have seen have
felt that 350 increase in the number of
kids with gun injuries last year here in
New York the teams are getting
increasingly fatigued trauma from having
to deal with not only children who have
gun injuries but their families and
constantly telling families that they've
either lost a loved one to a preventable
disease or that their kid is now
disabled for life or brain dead
and little children all the organs are
closer together and as a result every
bullet can injure that many more organs
and is that much more devastating than
let's say a bullet injury in a adult
we have a universal screening program
here in our emergency departments where
we actually screen all patients for
firearm injury risk and if you scream
positive for that there are resources we
can give you that help break that cycle
of violence before The Gunshot even
happens in the morning good morning AAP
guidelines suggests that the best advice
is to not have a gun in the home but for
those gun owners that actually do have
guns research shows that only 50 percent
of them are safely storing it so
something that we give out to our
patients are these cable locks this will
go through the unloaded empty firearm in
one spot there you'll lock it
comes out
a safe iron
when we talk about gun violence we are
referring to firearm related suicides
unintentional injuries otherwise known
as accidental injuries we're talking
about intentional firearm injuries which
could be firearm violence slash assault
or in a small sliver of cases things
like public mass shootings and it's
really important that we start having
this discussion in a very nuanced
granular way because that is the only
way that we're going to have a
productive conversation around potential
Solutions you can imagine that the
solutions to firearm suicide are far
different than the solutions needed to
stop mass shootings which are far
different than the solutions that are
needed for firearm violence we cannot
lump it all together
I've lived in the same house uh my whole
life and I I don't see myself moving
anytime soon we're here to stay City kid
growing up in this neighborhood of gun
violence and it's always been prevalent
always something I've seen around me it
just never dawned on me that it could
affect me in a way that would change my
life
the night of the shooting uh we had just
went on a family outing came back home
everyone was in bed I decided to go back
outside for a charger and I was sitting
in the passenger seat of the car and all
of a sudden someone runs up to the
driver's side they said something waved
some and symbols and and that was it
they just started unloading
when we got to the hospital the only
injury was gunshot wound to the back I
had a nicked vertebrae uh severed spinal
cord and uh both my lungs were ruptured
internal bleeding the whole nine yards I
still have the bullet in my chest today
I was in the hospital for about six
weeks I was on my mother's insurance I
was an HMO so we got lucky we didn't
have to pay for the visit but the visit
itself was north of a hundred thousand
dollars when I left the hospital I
thought the hardest part of the journey
was done but that was not true when I
got home I realized I got steps in the
front and the back and now I can't use
my legs how am I gonna get up there
while insurance providers tend to cover
the majority of medical bills
immediately following a shooting
Survivor State costs continue to wreck
up over time physical therapy or home
renovations may not be covered by
insurance and finding programs to help
cover the costs can be a challenge as a
result many patients have turned to
crowdsourcing to fundraise for ongoing
care needs there's a lot of things that
have had to come out of pocket because
they're just Niche enough for the
insurance not to cover them but uh
important enough that you actually need
them with a disability so I would say
roughly maybe 20 to 30 000 total as of
now has been paid out of pocket
[Music]
treating gunshot wounds and patients is
extremely expensive
we know that treating a patient with gun
injuries for example is three times more
expensive than treating any other type
of trauma this really speaks to the
complexities of the wounds the
complications that result from it and
the long ongoing disabilities that
really require a lot of intense medical
management so here we're seeing the gun
violence costs United States over 550
billion dollars per year which is an
extraordinary amount our politicians who
enabled this assault weapons ban in 1994
truly were Trailblazers at the time and
sadly the Clause was written that it
would sun down in 10 years so from my
perspective we're asking Washington DC
to re-initiate a law that was a law
we're not rewriting the history books
here we are asking them to continue the
history books
[Music]
the rates of gun violence are only going
up as we delve deeper and saw how much
of a problem this is these underserved
communities the health disparities
specifically brown and black communities
having horrific day-to-day gun violence
and losing many more brown and black
people to gun violence we realized that
we have to really broaden as Physicians
some of our lobbying
we do know that gun safety policies such
as assault weapon bans background checks
waiting periods licensing requirements
that most gun owners actually do support
will save lives and then we know that
other policies for example that address
the root causes of structural racism
inequity will improve firearm violence
in inner city communities so my question
really always is how can we have that
conversation in a way that legitimizes
both sides and their concerns that can
really lead to productive Solutions
rather than just this them versus US
discussion
you know
if this is the Public Health crisis that
we believe it is then gun violence
prevention is going to be a priority in
the next election and these lawmakers
need to be held accountable for their
decisions
childhood trauma and violence
perpetuates childhood trauma and
violence and so in this country as we
continue to have more and more gun
violence and children who are witnessing
these horrific events how it's affecting
their family they're actually more
likely to become violent themselves
we're trying to change the narrative in
our house to something terrible happened
and our parents did everything possible
to try to protect us
and teach them that despite adversity
that might happen we will always try to
rise above it and find solutions to
problems
but our question is back to lawmakers
have they done everything in their power
to save lives
[Music]
thank you